hey 42 here what would happen if all the
humans on earth disappeared tomorrow
well these real live ghost towns which
have all been abandoned for various
reasons give a glimpse into what life
will be like when nature is left to
reclaim man-made places first up is
Hashima island commonly referred to as
battleship island due to its resemblance
to a Japanese battleship on a side note
why do Japanese battleships look so darn
creepy this abandoned Island is one of
the 505 uninhabited islands of the
southwest coast of Japan what makes this
island different from its 504 over
neighboring islands is a Hashima island
used to be a thriving mining community
in 1887 during the industrialization of
Japan this island was set up as an
undersea coal mining facility many of
the miners lived on the island all year
round so the island function is an
offshore city including living quarters
and all the conveniences of a regular
city thousands of people lived and
worked on the island during his 87 years
of operation hitting a peak population
of 5259 people in 1959
however in 1974 the mine was closed down
and all the residents left the island
due to years of neglect and lack of
maintenance the island is now in ruins
Nature has reclaimed many of the
buildings which are now highly unstable
and many of them have collapsed the
whole island is like an eerie
post-apocalyptic nightmare speckled with
the faintest memories of miners who
spent their lives there it has since
become somewhat of a tourist attraction
in Japan but tourists should be wary as
it's a dangerous place that has seen no
maintenance and the buildings could
easily crumble at any moment ah Disney
World Florida full of happiness and
smugglers orchids surely nothing bad
could happen here
on the contrary you wouldn't think it
but Disney World Resort in Orlando
Florida is home to one of the most
bone-chilling abandoned places on earth
in 1965 Walt Disney bought an island in
the middle of Bay Lake at the Orlando
base Disney World Resort he originally
named it Treasure Island but later
changed it to Discovery Island to stop
people digging up the soil the island
was officially opened to guests in 1974
Discovery Island was a wildlife
attraction where guests could observe
rare species such as scarlet ibises
Galapagos Tortoises lemurs and many
others all was going well until July the
9th 1999 when the island was suddenly
closed to the public and all the animals
were hastily relocated to zoos away from
the island it isn't known why the
Discovery Island attraction was closed
but many rumors have suggested that a
bacterium capable of killing humans
called amoeba was discovered in the
waters surrounding the island oops
the island was simply abandoned and was
left to be taken over by the wild very
few have stepped foot on the island ever
since and today it's an eerie reminder
of the fun park attraction that once was
the island is full of abandoned
buildings and attractions all engulfed
by nature the island is now home to a
family of highly aggressive vultures as
well as some other bizarre items such as
preserved snakes in jars I've no idea
why this derelict in potentially
life-threatening island still sits
undisturbed and quietly concealing its
mysteries right in the middle of the
bright lights and commercial perfection
that is Disney World Florida it was the
early 21st century in Island and the
country was in the middle of a housing
bubble houses were selling like hotcakes
and property development was happening
at an unprecedented rate but then the
luck of the Irish ran out and in 2008
the housing market crashed thousands of
houses that were still in the middle of
development were simply never finished
and
abandoned due to a lack of funds and
falling demand these abandoned
residential estates were given highly
optimistic names such as Paradise Valley
however today they're nothing of the
sort
they're extremely creepy to witness and
are reminiscent of a post-apocalyptic
Desperate Housewives man that would be a
good show
they have since come to be known as the
ghost estates of Island somewhere that
looks this creep he just has to be
haunted
seeing these makes you think how strange
our world would appear with all the
humans suddenly disappeared just a
splattering of human life makes all the
difference between a cozy welcoming home
and this unnerving scene during World
War Two the British Navy built an array
of sea forts just off the southeast
coast of England called the Munsell
forts also commonly referred to as the
red Sun sea forts they may look like
8080 walkers but their purpose was not
to attack but to defend the United
Kingdom against German air raids
following the war they were
decommissioned in the 1950s
shortly afterwards however they were
used as pirate radio stations to
broadcast illegal radio waves across the
United Kingdom until they was shot down
by the British government in 1967
ever since the fort's have been
abandoned and now stand as an eerie
reminder of a truly horrific part of
history there is however a dispute going
on over who actually owns these forms a
man named Paddy Roy Bates purchased the
nearby rough sands fort in 1964 and
lived in it he decided to claim the fort
as his own country naming it the
Principality of Sealand he then told all
the other countries in Europe that
Zealand was an official principality and
they all said no no it's not Bates
however was adamant that Ceylon should
be an officially recognized nation and
to prove his point he claimed the
mon-sol sea forts as official London
property of Sealand yeah that'll show
him um no England basically said I don't
think so I'll chop their arse
give the
back the debate over their ownership and
whether the Principality of Sealand even
exists still goes on to this day just to
clarify things it totally doesn't exist
the United Nations Convention on the law
of the sea states artificial islands
installations and structures do not
possess the status of Islands they have
no territorial sea of their own yeah
sorry about that
Sealand next up is this UFO like
structure called buzz lugar first opened
in 1981 it was the home of the Bulgarian
Communist Party during the Soviet era
because of rectangular building is far
too capitalist this impressive piece of
Soviet architecture sits in the central
Balkan Mountains in Bulgaria it was this
ominous building where some of the most
infamous and controversial politics
originated from during the Cold War but
when the iron curtain fell in 1990
marking the end of the Soviet regime the
busloads er was completely abandoned
what was once a political powerhouse and
a global symbol of communism is now just
a chilling piece of history left to
succumb to the whims of the snow and ice
the building is now completely in ruins
and stepping inside it feels like
entering some kind of communist alien
spacecraft if that's even a thing I
wonder if they do have communism in
space the ruing Hotel in North Korea's
capital Pyongyang is not as totally
abandoned as the other locations on this
list well that doesn't change the fact
that it's bloody creepy construction of
this monolithic Oh two failed communism
began in 1987 when North Korea was
looking somewhat prosperous and was
expecting an influx of tourists who
witnessed a self-styled greatest nation
on earth
build it and they will come someone told
Kim il-sung but in the end no one came
the Soviet Union fell and in 1992 North
Korea ceased construction due to a lack
of funds you've got to give it to them
they don't do things by halves if North
Korea wants to build a tourist hotel
they're gonna build a bloody big
this 105 flawed Giants has stood
completely empty ever since it's now no
more than an overwhelming monument to
the Utopia that North Korea has tried
ever so hard to achieve but for the poor
unfortunate residents of the country has
sadly failed things started to appear
hopeful in 2008 when North Korea
announced that they had resumed work on
the hotel then in 2011 the exterior was
eventually completed with glass panels
it now looked slightly less intimidating
although the excitement was short-lived
North Korea couldn't muster up enough
funds to complete the interior the
opening of the hotel has been scheduled
numerous times in recent years but every
time it has been postponed probably due
to the fact that if you step inside the
hotel it's still a completely empty
shell at least that's what some sources
say after all North Korea is an
extremely secretive place who knows
what's actually going on inside there
they could be building North Korea's
very own Disneyland for all we know or
more likely concealing in missile
factory in the xijiang province of
eastern China
sits a large lake that holds an
underwater secret this Lake is called
key under way which translates as
Thousand Island Lake at the bottom of
this enormous body of water sits a
forgotten ancient city called Shi Cheng
which means Lion City the underwater
city of Shi Cheng is basically like the
lost city of Atlantis except we know
where this one is also Shi Cheng was
never actually lost in the first place
it was simply flooded and abandoned at
one time she Chang was a center of
economics and politics in eastern China
it was a huge beautiful city full of
dazzling white temples and archers paved
roads and thousands of houses the city
is steeped in heritage and culture built
1300 years ago this large ancient city
covers an area of approximately 62
football fields but the Chinese
government was obviously more concerned
with energy revenues than preserving
cultural heritage because in 1959 the
Chinese government flooded the valley
that sheets
sitsit to make a new artificial lake for
what's purpose well they decided a new
hydroelectric power station was required
and this would be the ideal location
this gigantic man-made reservoir which
has been named qiandao lake now hides
what once was and in some respects still
is one of the most beautiful cities that
China has ever known and lastly we have
the radioactive city of Pripyat on the
26th of April 1986 it reactor four of
the Chernobyl nuclear power plant in
Ukraine an argument broke out between
two senior nuclear engineers over
whether or not they should run a
potentially dangerous test on the
reactor they ended up running the test
and the nuclear reactor core
malfunctioned and tragically exploded
over the following weeks many tons of
highly radioactive cesium-137 was leaked
into the atmosphere from the still
burning reactor core the nuclear fallout
from the disaster covered much of Europe
one of the worst affected areas was a
nearby city of Pripyat which was built
to house workers at the Chernobyl
nuclear power plant in total 350,000 400
people from pre-pre art and from over
towns several miles around the disaster
area was permanently evacuated from
their homes an area covering a thousand
square miles around the Chernobyl plant
was completely abandoned due to it being
contaminated with fatal levels of
radiation this area known as the
exclusion zone or zone of alienation
which is way cooler is that the most
severely abandoned place on earth nature
has taken over and animals heavily
disfigured by radiation run wild with no
human competition these mutant animals
have claimed the exclusion zone as their
very own it's like an alien landscape
crossed with post-apocalyptic desolation
if it weren't so radioactive it would be
the perfect spot for a game of paintball
the trees in a four square mile area
surrounding the reactor core received a
severely large dose of radiation and was
subsequently killed the radiation caused
them to turn an E
reddish brown color because of this the
area has been given the name of the red
forest the red forest is one of the most
radioactive places in the world today
scientists say the exclusion zone will
not be safe enough for humans to Rhian
habit for another 20,000 years until an
it serves as a huge living laboratory
for scientists who measure the effects
of radiation poisoning on animals and
wildlife as well as a memorial to the
worst nuclear tragedy that has ever
happened thanks for the view subscribe
for more 42
you